so table comes first name as bonnibel
hopefully justice is a PvP yeah
oh no I thought they were just born with
the name like like dr. princess yeah
like that was just kind of in their name
so okay this is the cooler this end of
the so where the fire kingdom is
starting to cool down and a lot of the
characters seem to be disintegrating
what a treat did tied it disintegrates
which makes it mm-hmm
maybe he comes back after it gets put
that I'm not sure the one gun is
absorbed into the other yeah maybe hey
you know it's probably yeah so so they
figure they have to call in PB to help
things out and or BB now that we know um
and so she goes in and finds these giant
kind of like fire statue Giants or
something that are dangerous if not used
right I suppose could blow up their
their Kingdom which one of the
politicians there wants to do her
brother yeah her brother
yeah yeah that's right because he did
say sister so she has a much bigger
family than I remember I thought she was
kind of like an only child I'm like oh
and she has a couple brothers in the end
and the aunt that's right he's not very
smart no I'm not very smart so so Phoebe
goes in starts to take all the take the
essence of their power Phoebe
understandably gets really pissed off
because she finds out that she's been
spying on everybody and he's taking the
stuff away and interfering with how they
do things so she tries to blow her up
and then but realizes maybe it's full I
can feel I come from like five minutes
man I was trying to like hold that back
okay so so finally after they she takes
all the fire emblems or whatever they
are out she goes and leaves one up
saying you know okay I'll allow a little
bit of trust and then looks at her
I see Dark Knight style you know spying
on the city device and decides to unplug
them all and never spy on anyone again
well I'll see about that yeah yeah does
that seem in character there's even a
point where she says like yeah you're
spying on us she's like hey I'm Peavy
it's what I do it's like but you broke
our truce whatever is very funny but
yeah this seemed like a very um kind of
politically oriented one in a sense I
mean America has definitely had you know
it talks about this about we're all
being watched and spied on with and
stuff which yeah like the fly spy just
coorporate the fly spy um but but we
just thought all this time growing up I
don't know I just always Hannah and I'm
not a conspiracy nut I just kind of
assume we're all being watched somehow
anyway like when they made the discovery
holy shit oh my god I'm like really you
never honestly had even Bank your mind
maybe they were doing this like I'm not
saying it makes it right you know but
it's like kind of thought is probably
going on I never thought that like when
people talk about I'm like why why would
someone watch me oh no it's not you it's
everyone that's there but that that's
why I'm never concerned that's why is
that it's not me me it's just everyone
you know we're all you know kind of be
watching this fight I like I'm by no
means saying it's right I'm saying just
like I can't figure this was probably
going yes yeah just like I'm a boring
fellow I don't think and most people are
boring I don't think anyone would give a
shit well that's why yeah kind of like
Active Release it's like oh my god this
is a big mind blower which you know it
was that actual proof of this but then
at the same time probably whatever it's
like we're how dare they spy and show
you know I mean they can show anybody
anything that they want now let me take
pictures of my meal and put on Facebook
and Twitter
Blair it's like you're already doing
yeah I think it's one of the reasons
it's not as big a deal but yeah so this
one I mean really aside from the end
with some of the PB jokes like I said
you know it wasn't too much of like a
character-driven one as much as like an
ethical one if that makes sense I mean
it is nice to see Flame Princess again
and you know bubblegum because we were
just saying the last one like yeah we
haven't really seen that many characters
outside to Finn and Jake for a while so
it was okay um yeah it's about all I can
take for a minute Blaine put this way I
can see someone else watching this and
be like yeah like that God message
across I really believe in and really
stand behind it just like I said I kind
of grew up assuming this was being done
anyway so it didn't like hit it's close
to home to be but I can see somebody
else watching this like you know yes
that's right freedom and let us do you
know right to our privacy and stuff like
that so uh I don't know what you think
of it I didn't take it that way at all
no um well I mean okay
in the beginning I loved how like the
guy woke up jumped into his pants and he
talked about how diet and everything
it's great but that's not what I'm doing
so something's wrong yeah that doesn't
burst like third of it was pretty funny
with the flame person running and going
oh I love those hilarious PB showing up
I knew she was up to no good but I think
that was kind of the point with cuz
think about how much hatred for PB there
is I mean like a lot of people just
don't like her and I think this is
almost like the turning point where it's
like okay you know PB everyone knows PB
spies on everyone I mean it's obvious
and she doesn't hide it and I think
that's more what the whole wall of
screens were was like showing yeah
that's exactly who I am this is what I
do and no one seemed to ever attack her
and say you're not a good person
hmm they say you're weird or you're this
you hear that you shouldn't be so your
control free okay yeah but flame burns
justice says you're not a good person
and I think that's what hit PB the most
and she's like Oh cuz all the other
stuff she's like you know whatever what
you know what it is - I think because
even though people would probably
disagree with what she's doing the
reason she's doing it most people would
agree I'm sure she's doing it so it's
for the best interests of her kingdom
and her people and stuff like that and
that's the you know so it's like it's
all for the best interest so how could
this not how could I not be a good
person because I'm doing so much and
yeah that is kind of a lynchin point
that nobody is ever actually said you
are a bad person like you know what you
want is bad and I you're right that
probably did catch her very much
off-guard it's always the way you're
doing this is bad the way you're and
that was the first time she heard you
are a bad person and I think that's why
she they show this giant wall and it's
like okay you finally gets to see the
scope of how much she's watching and I
like house you know she's watching the
fire Kingdom and pulls those plugs I
think you so just see Finn and Jake
doing their student yeah and it's like
okay that's harmless that's stupid does
it really matter but then she just turns
them all off and I think it's more one
of those it's more of a turning point
for PB
kind of like maybe what I was doing
wasn't such a good thing and you know
what I'm gonna stop now you all know
what's so funny about that all the stuff
that kind of made her like I think
unlikable to other people's eyes I'm not
gonna add like I don't see how that's
possible or people can see that like
especially in this one I was like okay
she's really crossing some fucking lines
here like this is really going pretty
far uh you know and then when she unplug
them at the very end I I will admit I'm
wondering if that would make her
depending where they go kind of a less
interesting character because there was
always something very interesting that
she would kind especially it's like
really a politician that you know like
she has to make these choices that are
not easy choices there sometimes maybe
not even the right choices but you know
it's just the best at the moment or
something and you know serve walk that
ethical line of right and wrong and
that's part of what made her kind of
interesting because before she was just
like
bubblegum tea yaha you know and early on
but then she got like really interesting
and that she would be doing kind of this
stuff and she had like this science
background and she was all about like
the statistics and the numbers and she
kind of got colder and colder but that
made her actually more interesting so to
be I'm not saying they can't still make
her interesting I'm wondering though if
they sort of have like a plan for her I
mean maybe they can just play up kind of
the science aspect you know it kinda
nerdy aspect is now because there were
some episodes like where she's with like
Rainicorn and stuff like that yeah it's
like you know she didn't do anything
ethically like debatable but there was a
clear character there you know so it'll
be interesting to see what they do with
that they can still kind of make her
interesting cuz over the seasons she did
become more interest yeah you know and
not in a way of oh just give her count
what they do with boring characters just
give her a tragic backstory or yeah cry
a few times or something like that you
know and instant interest but no she was
actually like everything was calculating
in a statistic and was mathematical and
she was a scientist so it kind of made
sense and it she just seemed more cold
but was doing it for the good of
everybody so is she actually became
really interesting like anytime she
showed up on screen was kinda like
what's she up to
yeah what sort of alternate plot here
like that's how I always looked at it
and I think that probably is whether or
not he was planned or not that's part of
the fun of her starting out as kind of
just like you know the light-hearted
kind of Princess Toadstool type
character and sort of shifting into this
because so much of being a politician is
the image yeah you know and you know
that as long as you look you know
they've happy and confident and you know
good looking at all that stuff it'll
increase your chances of people not
suspecting you doing anything even if
you think it's in their best interest
yeah
so it's so you look Purdy and have a
smile on your face you can be caught
red-handed and it's still kind of oh
good yeah you get that you can still
kind of like play it off alright so yeah
I'd be interested to see if my guess
would be they did not have a plan but I
don't know and I'll start wondering
maybe that was sort of the idea she
starts off it's like just sort of the
happy-go-lucky politician and then
slowly discovered more and more yeah and
like that a richer I would think no but
the more political to get into it the
more I'm like that is kind of how
politics works you want to look really
happy and confident and you know so that
they don't suspect as much yeah you know
what you're doing but even if you're
doing bad stuff I believe every
politician believes they're doing it for
the good of the people they're doing it
for the greater good
well get a majority I'll say I don't
know if I I'd say the minority believes
that the majority is kind of like a
cache I'll actually say majority I'm
more optimistic though I totally I'm not
saying I'm right that would be 100%
right uh but I'll be optimistic and save
the majority um
I can't see all these people going into
politics I mean so many people in policy
yes going in guys through people over
now it's but I think that what happens
in politics yeah you just take a pill
and boom you're you're thinking evil for
everybody it's great but you get to
screw people over and make money yeah oh
that's politics out of nacho I'm in the
wrong bitch yes okay faux fur laws